friends happy Tuesday
welcome back to the rstudio Enterprise
Community Meetup hope everyone's having
a great start to the week
if you just join now feel free to say hi
through the chat window and maybe where
you're calling in from
today we are doing something a little
different and have three of our product
managers here with us today for a
lightning series to hear what's new ask
questions and provide feedback
if you like this format please let us
know I'm hoping the recording will be a
helpful resource for the others as well
so we'll have three lightning talks for
you today one sharing internal packages
for uh with our studio package manager
the second running our studio workloads
in the cloud with Amazon sagemaker and
third content execution in kubernetes
with rstudio connect
a special welcome if this is your first
time joining us today
this is a friendly and open Meetup
environment for teens to share use cases
teach lessons learned and just meet each
other and ask questions
so they happen every Tuesday at noon
Eastern Time
I'll share a link in the chat where you
can also find out about upcoming meetups
too
but it's just
rstd.io Community Dash events
together we're all dedicated to making
this space inclusive and an open
environment for everybody no matter your
experience your industry your background
so during the event you are able to also
ask anonymous questions if you wish
through a short link which I'll share
here on the screen in a second as well
I'm bad at multitasking right here but
we'll try to answer as many questions as
possible and want to hear lots of
questions from you all
each of our product managers joining us
here today provided a question as well
so that we can learn more from you too
and so that will be at the same slido
link there's an anonymous poll there as
well
but with that said I would love to bring
my colleagues Joe James and Kelly on
stage with me here as well to introduce
themselves and I'll just bring you up
here on stage
James would you want to get started in
introducing yourself trying to pull
Kelly up and yeah there we go
my name is James Blair and I work at
rstudio as a product manager for cloud
Integrations and happy to be with you
all today
awesome Kelly you want to go next
sure I'm Kelly I'm the product manager
for our studio connect
and last but not least Joe yeah I'm Joe
Robertson I am the product manager for
the rstudio package manager
thank you all so much for uh jumping in
here and experimenting with us here
today Joe I know we have you
um
slated first and it looks like the
screen share is looking good over here
on the side so I'm gonna pull it over
yeah
all right
well yeah hi everyone I so I just wanted
to do a quick lightning talk about the
um sharing internal packages with our
studio package manager and um and I
apologize if
I have technical difficulties with this
we can switch things over but um
hopefully this goes through okay
um
so the
question is
um
let's see are we using your slide there
there we go okay
um so uh for those who aren't aware what
package manager is it's uh it's one of
our tools for centralizing the
governance of your data science packages
so
um really what you can do everything
from
um mirroring your public repositories
internally so whether you are looking at
uh using a cran or bio conductor or Pi
Pi
um public repository you want to bring
that inside your network and host it
from a server locally in your in your
network
um near that there you can also curate
custom subsets of those public
repositories to make kind of a new meta
subset repository one of our primary
features there is also being able to
time travel to older versions of
packages we keep a
um a snapshot of every day of all of
these major the big repositories and so
we can actually let you know if you need
to for reproducibility or any other
reason roll back to a specific version a
date of
um of cran for example you can just
easily roll back to that and say let's
reproduce my my project and my code
against the current these the version of
the packages that were in place when I
developed those
and then most importantly for today
anyway what we're going to talk about is
how you can share internally developed
packages using package manager
so um
so there are um
the the concept revolves around what we
call local package sources which allow
you to take a uh build your package
however you normally would do that in
normally using like you know R directly
to uh build or any of the tools in there
and then add those to your local local
source and package manager
that makes them stored in there and
visible as a separate repository or can
also be joined to a cran mirror source
to make one unified repository that
contains both your public and private
packages which makes it easy because
then all of your you know users can
access uh both cran packages and your
local packages from a sim a single
repository URL in uh in our and
similarly for for python for Pi Pi
um and and so being able to do that and
then also supporting
um the more advantages than just say the
some other alternative for local sources
include support that we now have that we
just recently added for custom pre-built
binary packages
um for for those who uh are new to the
world and binary packages most packages
that you receive from um especially on
Linux for example on cran
um our source packages which means that
in order to install the package on your
on your local R installation there you
actually have to download the package
and actually build the package when you
when you install it
um we crayon provides binaries pre-built
binary packages for both Windows and Mac
OS which allow you to just download
install it without having to worry about
building it there we extend that support
to also Linux as well as uh
providing our own
um uh through package manager providing
we build all of the cram packages for
example on Linux various about eight
different distributions so that your
users can no matter what distribution
they're what's a prep platform they're
on they can install packages easily
um and then we also support multiple R
versions of packages so so if you need
different versions of your of your
package for
um and you know some users on older
versions of R you can support both of
those simultaneously and as I said
multiple platforms
so one way we make this easier than just
the the manual method of taking you know
building your own packages and uploading
them to package manager is through git
Builders which we actually include is a
feature within package manager and it'll
we include simple package builders that
can uh that you can point to a if your
packages are stored in a git project
monitor that git project for any changes
on whether it's a change in the tag or a
change in the uh or at just any uh push
to the git repository and then whenever
that changes happens we will actually
build that rebuild that package from the
new source and publish that package
straight into package manager making
that available to to whoever you have
using that uh local Source repository in
uh from package manager
yeah it makes it simple to get out of
the box out of the box functionality
that can just make it easy to integrate
with you know when you have it use users
who are publishing updates to get and
want to be able to to bring those in to
make them available
one limitation of our git Builders is
they are best for simple quick builds
um they only handle Source packages so
like I just was mentioning it with the
binary packages you have to do another
um yep another more manual step on that
um you don't get that out of the box
however
um we've just released some new features
to allow better Integrations with your
own build pipelines they give you a far
more customizable feature for building
packages
and so we both um so what we've
released are some some tools to actually
integrate remotely whether you're where
your build pipeline you know we'd say
build pipelines most people either have
these in you know there's several most
common ones out there GitHub has their
own GitHub workflows and GitHub actions
that allow you to to build uh have
GitHub build them automatically in the
background and then publish those and
then also you know there's common uh
build infrastructures commonly you know
continuous integration continuous
delivery pipelines like Jenkins that
um can be brought up as well and all of
these to say you can then just integrate
plug plug remote our remote publishing
API directly into your build Pipeline
and then uh go build whatever you want
Source binary add whatever package build
and validation features whether you want
to add checks and validation to your
builds dependencies scanning any sort of
automated testing you want to have in
that do all any basically do the war
whoever want to do
um to make to make sure that you create
the best packages and then automatically
at the end of that process publish those
to up to an updated version of your
packages to to package manager
um and so basically allows you to take
it the full advantage of the full
functionality that's available in these
build pipelines including things like
custom build triggers where as I
mentioned our git Builders can trigger
based on say updates to
um to a git Repository
the amount of bill the bill triggers in
some a lot of these build pipelines
include things like if you just want to
have a nightly build for example that
every night I want this to build um and
publish a new version
um and also much more a wide range of
reporting and notifications so you can
actually be you know send people
notifications hey there's a new version
of this package that's been built and
published and here's the changes and
things like that everything that you
would want in a in a full build pipeline
so um coming all that to say why why do
why does it matter why should you want
to care about this I mean most of you
probably know that developing packages
is probably the best way to share your
reusable code with others and so
um many of you are probably consumers of
packages but also develop your own
things that would be great if I could
share this with others um on my team
even um outside my team if they're if
you wanted to and you know all of the
main R and python have great ways and
have built great ecosystems around
packaging up your code into a reusable
format that you can give to others
package manager helps you easily make
those packages available within your
organization and as I pointed out in a
real really unified repository way which
makes it easy for those on that are
actually using your packages to access
them and browse them and find them
easily which is why for example you can
actually
um package manager also has a user
interface and that you can view from
your web browser so you can actually
curate a repository of these packages
and make it very easy including
documentation explain you know you know
descriptions of why these packages might
be useful for people who are trying to
find them and really curate your own
your own cran or Pi Pi uh in that
and uh
so in summary you know local sources are
currently available for our packages we
are working on python package support
that will be coming very soon before the
end of the year which is very exciting
so we can bring that across the entire
ecosystem of um because our goal in the
upcoming uh few months and year is to
provide the same level of support for
python packages that we currently do for
our packages
and definitely feel free to check out
packagemanager.r studio.com which is our
public package manager instance to
explore
um we have public mirrors of crayon
bioconductor and Pipi that you can
easily configure with your r or Python
and and see some of the benefits of
their uh automatically free on our
public side includes taking advantage of
our snapshots and time traveling to
earlier versions and uh and
and if you have any more questions feel
free to reach out to our studio and
we're happy to give you more information
and show you more of the features of
package manager
thank you everybody and uh thanks for
the questions
awesome thank you so much Joe
I was uh trying to copy over to LinkedIn
to just say if you'd also like to ask
questions anonymously or answer the poll
that I mentioned I'm just copying that
over to LinkedIn right now but I'm going
to share that on the screen here too
foreign
so you can either ask questions in
YouTube if you're watching there or on
LinkedIn in the chat if you're asking
there and then this link here is for the
anonymous questions too
I see somebody put into YouTube I vote
for a package manager special session as
well
I'd love to do one sometime yes
awesome
um I see Laura asks a great question on
slido which I'm going to copy over here
to show on the screen too
so just a second
I was helping with the screen share here
so I didn't want to do anything in the
uh the background
there we go
um
so Laura said uh keep on local Source
first add to crayon mirror source is
there a major headache annoyance or
difference on user or package maintainer
side for internal packages
well for internal packages I I hope I
understand the question here I mean the
I guess whether you want to keep it on a
separate local source that you just
curate yourself versus doing a unified
adding it merging it with for a unified
source with a cran mirror
um from a user perspective it definitely
is easier if you have a one unified URL
because you only have to give your user
and have them configure one repository
URL in um their our client or our studio
wherever wherever they're using are
um uh though there can be um and even
with a unified
um uh the one advantage can be with
keeping it separate is you actually have
a separate repository just of your local
packages which can make it a little
easier for discoverability with that
there too so they can just see these are
all of our local packages versus a
unified repository that has everything
but then they also have to have
configure multiple repository URLs um to
have both the local package source and
the uh the uh crayon package Source but
that's not
it's kind of a one-time deal sometimes
that you just have to do once and it can
make it easier to keep things separate
thank you um I see another question on
slido and we'll take two questions and
be each for for each presentation then
hold some of the other questions to the
end as well
um but the question is
how does the external publishing Feature
work is the CI pipeline tool pushing it
via an API is that feature documented
already yes it is
um and so we have released uh basically
a remote version of our um the command
line interface that we use on the server
for for uh interacting with uh
administering
uh package manager and so now we have a
downloadable remote API that you can use
and the it's secured via API tokens that
you generate so a server administrator
will generate an API token that they
then give to whoever wants to use this
publishing API and then they they can
actually use that remotely hook that up
there and just use the same um the same
command the same commands that you would
use on this on the server itself to
remote on the remote API the remote CLI
to publish that uh to to package manager
and that is documented in our
documentation
um and I'll find a link and post it into
the chat here
awesome I was just going to say that
yeah if you wanted to even put in the
private chat there or in the chat on
YouTube I can copy it over as well great
thank you so much Joe thank you really
appreciate it and I think next in our
schedule I'll be turning it over to
James Blair who will be presenting on
running our studio workloads in the
cloud with Amazon sagemaker
let me pull your screen up here James
there we go
great actually this question there we go
okay well I'm excited to be here so like
Rachel said we're going to talk briefly
about running our studio workloads in
Amazon sagemaker and just as like a
really quick introduction uh we'll be
focused on our studio workbench today if
you've never used our studio workbench
before
um the easiest way to think about it is
it's a
version of our studio essentially that's
accessible through a browser that's
running on infrastructure elsewhere that
could be infrastructure within your own
organization it could be infrastructure
in the cloud like Amazon's Age Maker or
something else but it's typically
something you would access to your
browser and the advantage one of the
distinct advantages of our city
workbench is that it gives you access to
a much larger collection of compute
resources than you would have just on
your own little like local desktop or
laptop installation and we'll highlight
that when we talk about the integration
with sagemaker today
the other piece of this is obviously
Amazon sagemaker um I'm not going to go
terribly in depth into the sagemaker
platform as a whole again we'll be
focused on the RCB workbench integration
but Amazon Sage maker is an entire
collection of different tools and
resources on the Amazon web services
platform that's centered around the task
of machine learning and data science so
there's tools for model training and
monitoring and deployment and prediction
and batch jobs and all kinds of
different things and then at the core of
all that there are a couple of different
development environments that you can
use to orchestrate some of this work and
our studio workbench is one of those
environments that can be made available
so that little bit of an introduction I
want to give just a little bit of
background about our studio workbench on
sagemaker it's been around for about a
year so launched in November of 2021 uh
we've seen really good adoption with it
we've seen a lot of uh
um customers happy with the engagement
happy with the integration and and it's
worked really well for them the thing
that's kind of most interesting or I
think is is kind of most interesting
about this integration is the fact that
Amazon worked with us and we worked with
them to to build kind of this custom
implementation of what we call the
launcher which is just a component of
sorts that's involved in our CD
workbench that allows external
architectures to run sessions and
workloads
um natively job launcher supports
kubernetes and slurm uh which is
something that we see we've seen a lot
of organizations adopt but then
sagemaker implemented their own kind of
unique implementation of this that's
backed by ec2 as an environment
and we'll take a look at what all this
means in a moment the other kind of core
things that I think are really like
really highlight the strengths of rcd
workbench on sagemaker are the fact that
it's low maintenance infrastructure so
you set up your sagemaker environment
but then you don't need to set up
additional components to support the
workloads that are being run sagemaker
actually takes care of all that which is
which is just a nice convenience factor
and the other component here is that you
have the ability to create these kind of
quote-unquote right size sessions so
users can go in and say hey I need a lot
of CPU and a lot of memory because I'm
doing something really big or another
user might want to say look I'm not
doing like a huge scale analysis I need
like I don't need a bunch of resources
and so they can be more selective about
the resources that they need and that
can both save cost over time but also
like serve as an enabler for your data
science teams because individuals can
can perform analyzes regardless of the
resource requirements of those analyzes
foreign
so just a little bit of an idea of the
like the infrastructure behind it and
architecture behind this and it's like
this isn't important to you don't worry
about it like this is not something
that's critical to to understand in
order to use the platform but I do find
this a little bit interesting that users
so are little happy users over here on
the left hand side come into our studio
workbench there's a central server
that's running our studio workbench that
server gets set up as part of your
sagemaker domain setup process
um this is licensed through AWS license
manager so if you wanted to run our
studio workbench in sagemaker you do
need an rcd workbench license and that
license is delivered and managed through
the AWS license manager there's a couple
of different ways to do that I'm not
actually going to dive into the details
here in this in this conversation but
just note that you do need a new license
and it gets delivered through AWS
license manager and then individual user
sessions so these users come in they say
hey I need to run a session of our
studio and then these individual
sessions run in their own separate
dedicated compute instances that are
running a Docker container that supports
the session execution of our studio
workbench so we're going to take a look
at what all this means in practice but
it might in my case it's helpful to have
kind of a mental model of what's
Happening behind the scenes so maybe
this proves useful if it doesn't like I
said this isn't something that's
necessary to understand in order to use
the platform
okay so with that little bit of
background we're going to jump into
siegemaker now and just kind of take a
look at what this looks like in practice
and some of the advantages that we've
highlighted will kind of show what those
look like in the in the platform itself
this is my sagemaker control panel
within AWS and so I have users here I
can see different services and apps that
are available I can see over here on the
right hand side I have our studio but
for an individual user so I'm James so
I'll come in here and under the James
user I can click launch app and then
I'll see the r studio is one of the
applications that I can launch inside of
sagemaker and if I select this it'll
open up in fact we'll just do it here if
I select this it'll open up the rstudio
workbench homepage which looks like this
again if you've used our studio
workbench previously or currently this
page likely looks familiar to you if
you've only used like the open source
rstudio desktop this page is probably
unfamiliar because the desktop doesn't
have any equivalent page here and that's
just because like the desktop setup is a
little bit different you're not
typically running concurrent sessions
launched from the same route
um which which is a common use case in
our studio workbench but the idea is I
can come in here you can see that I have
a couple of sessions already running
we'll take a look at those in a moment
but typically this would be blank and I
would the first thing I would do is
start a new session
and once I pull this open I can name my
session new session whatever the case is
I can Define the editor that I'm going
to use in this case I'm on sagemaker and
the only editor that I have available to
me in rstudio is the rstudio editor and
and that's the familiar again if you use
rstudio on any context desktop server
whatever the case is our studio is that
familiar editor and we'll take a look in
a moment the cluster is sagemaker again
I do not have the option to choose
anything other than sagemaker here
because I'm working inside the sagemaker
environment
and then down below under options here's
where I have two things that I can
really adjust the first thing is the
instance type so this is the ec2
environment that I want to run the
session on so I have like a very small
kind of default environment that
contains just a couple of virtual CPUs
and like four gigabytes of RAM I think
it's a pretty small instance but for
some workloads that might be totally
sufficient and then I can scale all the
way up to like some of these some of
these are GPU instances if I was trying
to do GPU workloads some of these like
compute optimized instances have up to
like 128 uh CPU cores and hundreds of
gigabytes of memory available uh and and
I can choose as the user what kind of
resources I need for my session before I
before I start the session so I make the
choice from an instance type the other
option that I have is the image that I
want to run there's currently one base
image that sagemaker provides which is
this image that I have selected here
it's actually starting to get a bit old
so we're working with the sagemaker team
to see if we can get an update here for
the default but there's also the
opportunity if you find that this
default is insufficient maybe it doesn't
have the right version of r or it
doesn't have the Right Packages
installed or it doesn't have the right
system dependencies whatever the case is
um you have the ability to Define your
own Docker image and make that available
within sagemaker so you can you can be
really flexible around what type of of
like operating system and environment
your session is running in by creating
these custom images and then configuring
them to be made available to users
within within our studio on sagemaker
once I've gone through this whole
process I would click Start session it
actually takes a little bit of time to
start a new session inside of sagemaker
because of all the behind the scenes
work that needs to be done we have to
provision an ec2 environment we have to
copy an image into that environment we
have to run the image as a container and
so it can take a couple of minutes to
start a session so I'm actually just
going to use the sessions that I already
have started just so that we can avoid
waiting around but if I look for example
at this R studio session and look at the
info here I can see that this is running
on it should simply tell me right here
it was running on T3 medium instance and
it gives me some some additional details
about the environment that this is
running on if I if I'm interested in it
if I click into the session this is
where we will all likely feel at home
right this is the rstudio IDE that we
have likely gained quite a bit of
experience with again whether that
experience has come from the desktop or
something that's browser-based like what
we're using here doesn't matter the user
experience is essentially the same I can
write our code I can write our markdown
documents I can execute that code in the
console I can view plots and navigate my
files and I can interact with Git and I
can view connections and and make
connections to databases anything that I
would expect to be able to do I could do
inside of this environment but I wanted
to highlight if I look over here and I
look at let's just do this
so if we look at this particular session
we can see that I have two CPU cores
available to me because this is a pretty
small instance that I've chosen and then
if we look at the available memory I
have about four gigabytes of memory on
this on this particular server and the
thing that's important to note is that
this is like my own little server it's
like I've I've created my own little
tiny environment in the cloud and it's
mine and mine alone so these resources
even though they might be small aren't
going to be constrained by other users
doing things they're just mine to
conceal uh which which is really nice
what that means is if I start a session
um and then my co-worker also starts a
session and they do something
unexpected and their session ends up
getting stuck right they consume more
memory than they have available or they
max out the CPU or whatever they might
do
then then that's something that they'll
have to work through right they'll have
to close down that session and maybe
start a new one with more resources but
it doesn't affect me right if if
somebody else's session goes a little
bit awry it's not going to affect mine
because they're all totally independent
there's no kind of shared underlying
infrastructure here other than the Like
Home Server and it's not actually
executing anything it's just farming the
execution out to these different
environments
um okay so here's that example now let's
come back to the homepage for a moment
and let's look at this larger session
again notice that these are two separate
sessions that I'm running as one user
from our studio workbench inside of
sagemaker and if we remember right we
had two available
um cores CPU cores in the previous
session and we had about four gigabytes
of RAM if we look at the same statistics
here let's just run it in real time so
that we know that we're getting the
right results in this session I have 48
cores available and I have
92 available gigabytes of memory so
quite a quite a vast difference between
these two sessions and this isn't even
one of the largest sessions that I could
have created right again I can go up to
over 100 cores of available CPU power
and and several hundred gigabytes of
memory if I need to and again this is
just my environment so if I decide as
the as the data scientist or as the
statistician that I need a lot of power
for my analysis maybe I'm dealing with
really large data or I'm planning on
doing something massively in parallel
whatever the case is I can choose the
right instance when I set my session up
so that I have support for the work that
I'm going to be doing
the last thing that I want to show in
here I'm going to come back to our other
session for a moment is I can also
because I'm inside of the AWS ecosystem
and more specifically because I'm
working inside of sagemaker if I wanted
to do something like kick off uh an
asynchronous training job given some
data that I had stored in S3 I can do
all of that by using the sagemaker SDK
so right here let me expand this a
little bit right here this particular
portion of this our markdown document
loads in the reticulate package which is
an art package for interfacing between R
and Python and then there's not really a
well-developed r SDK or r package for
working with sagemaker but there is a
really well developed and Amazon
supported python package for working
with sagemaker so I'm going to use the
reticulate r package to bring in this
python sagemaker package and then I can
use that to interact with my session and
I can do things like create training
jobs and create pipelines and execute
training jobs and submit batch
predictions and I can orchestrate all
that from within our studio here on the
sagemaker platform and the thing that's
kind of fun is if I in fact if I just
run this chunk of code here
because it'll run through and everything
and then it will print out this this uh
roll identifier down here that I'll use
later on in this script to orchestrate
some things but if you look and I
apologize for the scrolling back and
forth but if you look I'm at the very
beginning of my script here I'm at the
very beginning of my session and I
haven't actually passed in any
credentials right I haven't said like
here's my token or here's my key or
here's my password
um and the reason for that is because
I'm already running on Amazon
infrastructure and when sagemaker
provisioned the little ec2 server for my
session it supplied that server with an
IEM role that matches the role that I
have as a user so whenever I then use
that particular server to interact with
other services within sagemaker or
within AWS like I'm doing here it
automatically picks up those credentials
and just applies their the appropriate
permissions and and that's just like
that's nothing more than just a
convenience factor meaning that like
once I get into this environment if I
wanted to query something that was
stored in S3 or interact with other
sagemaker services or submit queries to
Athena or whatever the case is I can do
all those operations without needing to
constantly like Supply some sort of
token or identifier to to authenticate
myself to those other services my
identity just kind of follows me around
in this particular case
um
okay
so I'm gonna go ahead and kind of wrap
things up there and come back to slides
here I don't really have a conclusion
concluding slide but I did want to just
come back to these points here and
highlight once again that one of the
distinct advantages of this particular
environment is that as an organization I
don't have to maintain a lot of like
custom infrastructure to support
flexible compute right this is like I
set up my sagemaker domain and then I
just let sagemaker handle everything
else so I don't need to worry about how
to spin up instances when users need
them or how to tear them down sagemaker
will take care of all that for me and it
allows my individual data scientists to
operate with resources that match the
workload that they're doing whether
those resources are small or large uh
the burden Falls of the individual data
scientists to make the correct decision
about do I need a lot of stuff you know
do I need do I need a ton of CPU and a
ton of memory or can I get away with
with just a smaller instance
um so if you have more questions about
this topic or if you're interested in
like a a longer form discussion about
rstudio on sagemaker or rcd on the cloud
and the Integrations that we're working
on there let us know I'm sure that's
something that we'd be happy to put
together
um and also feel free to reach out to us
at our studio too if there's additional
questions we can we can always find a
way to answer those but um but it looks
like there's questions coming in I'll
actually turn things back to Rachel to
kind of moderate the questions but uh
anyway appreciate everybody's time yeah
thank you so much James and uh I I know
we both just mentioned like if you do
want to chat with with our studio so I
figured I should show this on the screen
too if you do have follow-up questions
about this and ever want to schedule a
time to to chat with our team you could
use that short link there
um but there are a few questions over on
slido and before I pull those up I just
want to remind everybody because I know
people come in at different times as
well if you're on LinkedIn right now you
can ask questions there in the chat if
you're on YouTube you can ask questions
there or you can use this short link
here on the screen to ask questions
anonymously and there's also a poll
there with a few questions from the
speakers if you feel like answering that
as well your feedback there is really
really helpful
um but one of the questions over on
slido now is
where can I find release notes for
workbench on sagemaker for example new
features added or new versions of R
supported I haven't seen these on AWS or
our studio
yeah there's not there's not a good spot
for those so there's it's kind of this
interesting intersection of two things
right there's the RCA workbench
component that goes to its regular
release cycle and so we we provide
extensive release notes with every
release to our studio workbench but then
sagemaker updates kind of on their own
cycle right sagemaker for right for
example right now is several versions
behind on workbench and they're working
on rolling out a more recent release as
we speak
um so so there's like those two
components there is a section and I'll
find it here in a moment and and pass
over to Rachel so it can be surfaced in
the chat and in other places here but
there's a piece of documentation that
Amazon maintains that highlights like
what's different or unique about our
studio workbench in sagemaker and so the
real like answer this question is kind
of a combination of two things one is
checking those differences to see kind
of what what the what Amazon's reporting
in terms of like what things they've not
necessarily changed but there's certain
features that they've disabled and
there's certain things that are a little
bit different about how our studio
workbench operates in sagemaker and then
the other piece is identifying what
version of workbench is being run in
sagemaker and then checking the release
notes that we put out that correspond to
that version and that will let you know
kind of what's changed with that
particular version I am aware that
micros or not Microsoft that Amazon
doesn't do a great job of making it
really transparent in terms of what
version of workbench they're running as
far as I know the only way to find out
is to like go into work binge on
sagemaker and check the version from
there which isn't ideal um and so I
brought this up with them and they have
plans uh or at least they've shared with
me there's some plans to to provide that
very version number in their
documentation so it's a little bit
easier to like do that exercise of
comparing back to the release notes so
like basically the short answer here is
there's not a great single source for
that there's a couple of different
places I would look to kind of piece
that story together
Thanks James and you can share those
links with us
yes yeah
okay perfect
um and then one of the other questions
on slido was how are the instances
cleaned up after use so they don't incur
unnecessary cost
yeah excellent question so there's no
sagemaker itself as a platform doesn't
have any sort of like auto shutoff
features and the same is true on the
sagemaker studio side so sagemaker
studio is a is a Jupiter based platform
that sagemaker rolled out several years
ago in the sagemaker platform first came
out of the scene and that's that's where
like a lot of sagemaker development has
happened historically and then now
there's this new rstudio component you
could also use in both cases these ect's
kind of ephemeral ec2 instances can be
created pretty easily by end users to do
different tasks and analyzes but there's
no sort of like Auto termination
functionality right now it's it's
certainly something I've brought up with
the with the Amazon team and something
they're aware of
um but for now there's no sort of Auto
termination so it really falls back on
the end user to clean up after
themselves by shutting down their
session so from our studio if you just
like close out of the session and then
from the home page you can choose to
like quit the session out completely and
once that action has happened the ec2
instance is is terminated and so you
don't continue to incur cost at that
point it's just a matter of training
users and helping them understand that
usage pattern
great I just saw one quick question run
into YouTube as well so I'm going to
show that and then we'll turn it over to
Kelly
um but Nick asked how is persistent data
handled for these kinds of deployments
awesome I'm so glad this question was
asked because I meant to cover this and
realized I totally didn't so Amazon I
think has done a really really awesome
job in this particular Department the
whole integration I think is great but
this particularly like shows a lot of a
lot of thought and what happens is when
you create a sagemaker domain
um there's there's a persistent
um EFS Mount that gets created as part
of that domain and that that mount
stores user home directories and it's
this is all behind the scenes stuff it's
not anything that you need to like
specify or create yourself that's just
part of the process of what happens and
so as an individual user in our studio
what this means is if I go in and like
clone a repository or download a package
and install it or whatever the case is
in like unless I'm doing something
atypical all that stuff's going to end
up in my home directory and that home
directory is automatically persistent so
if I start a session and I install a
package and then I close the session and
two weeks later I start a new session
that package is still going to be there
and work that I was working on in my
home directory or a subsequent directory
is also going to be there that all just
follows me around and I don't have to I
don't have to do anything else to to
make that happen it just is part of the
the experience that Amazon provides
great thank you so much James
and now I'd love to turn it over to you
Kelly and let me promote your
screen here Kelly will be sharing on
content execution and kubernetes with
our with connect
oh sorry I think we are muted Kelly here
we go
yeah thanks all right
um thank you for inviting me I uh when
Rachel asked you know what's new with
connect what can we talk about for
meetup this week I am in the fortunate
position of having a lot of options
because we've released a bunch of cool
things in connect this year we tend to
release monthly so if you want to follow
along with what has landed in the
product on a month by month basis you
can do that by looking at our release
notes which are kept in the product
documentation page
but I wanted to highlight and call
special attention to this body of work
on office content execution for connect
on kubernetes because it represents an
investment uh project that we've been
working on literally since I became a
product manager here so going on on two
years and we hit a huge milestone this
summer when we announced our public Beta
release at the art studio conference and
I wanted to go through what that means
for us and talk about how we're moving
towards General availability for this
feature set as well so that'll be what I
covered today
um I'll back up though a little bit to
start and talk about what connect is if
you haven't heard of connect it's our
platform for publishing all of the
things that you build in R and python
your data products to a server that can
be used to execute your content and
share it with other people inside of
your organization
so you can create things like shiny apps
interactive python applications apis
documents you can run those things on a
schedule you can share them with people
and connect helps you do all of those
things in a way that you can manage as a
data scientist without having to worry
about standing up the necessary
infrastructure yourself once you get
over the hurdle of putting connect
online itself
but today if you are using our studio
connect
fundamentally even though you can run
multiple versions of R and multiple
versions of python for your different
content you can have multiple package
sets that support your different content
items those content items are sandboxed
apart from one another so that my shiny
application doesn't mess with Joe's
python app
all of those things fundamentally are
running using local processes on the
same host or container as the connect
server itself
and that's what we're calling attention
to on this slide because it highlights
our next iteration of what comes next
for connect so what we've enabled now
with the our studio launcher product uh
and packaging that inside of of connect
itself is a method of off host content
execution specifically in kubernetes
environments
so using this Paradigm kubernetes is
used to execute content
and jobs are running external to The
Container that's running connect itself
so we've added this layer of separation
why you might want to do that is to make
use of native execution paradigms you
might want that additional layer of
separation between your content items
you might want to run different
underlying container images or operating
systems even to support different
content items it could make migrating
from operating system to operating
system easier in the future
a lot of of great benefits come from
adopting this kind of execution Paradigm
so it can be very powerful both from a
user perspective as a data scientist and
also from an admin perspective if you or
your organization has decided to adopt
kubernetes we now
support
that type of of environment execution in
a much more native way
so if you are of the admin uh
perspective these are kind of the the
nitty-gritty the connector requirements
for running in our post execution are
a modern version of of connect itself
you should be running hopefully like the
latest version of connect which our
latest releases our September Edition
but at the very least use our July
Edition which is when we announce the
public beta you need a valid license a
TLS certificate of tea you need to use a
postgres database and you need some sort
of file storage there are NFS or EFS to
set this up
you'll also need
obviously you're working kubernetes
cluster and the
Cube CTL kubernetes command line tool
and
which is this package manager for
kubernetes
if you want to see uh
a wild Speed Run installation that I
attempted at the uh our studio
conference you can watch the our studio
conf 2022 talk where I go through all of
the documentation for running through a
Helm chart installation on eks from
start to finish and that was all
captured I probably need to re-record
that because I had the most covid while
I was trying to give that talk remotely
so I'll get a cleaner version of that
recorded and put up on YouTube pretty
soon here but shows you just in a very
short amount of time how quickly you can
get up and running with connect on
kubernetes
and then I did want to cover what public
beta means so this is an open invitation
to try it out provide feedback to us
um support as you interact with it for
regular connect today is fully available
but we are saying because we do not have
the full feature set that we would like
to enable uh available yet use some
production isn't recommended uh at this
time but we'd love to talk to you if if
you're interested if your it admins are
interested in having this conversation
about moving your connect instance to
kubernetes
um we'd love to have that architecture
review an intro call with you and we're
currently doing some some more Hands-On
guided installations just so that our
internal teams can get more training on
this new paradigm for connect as well so
if if you are interested in taking the
tires on the data and have a great time
because you get even even more attention
from our Solutions engineering and
support teams as we're all working
together to learn
about how the soul the soul work as we
move towards General availability
when will it be generally available is a
question that uh I've been getting a lot
and we don't have a date for that yet uh
we'd love for you to sign up to get
product information emails and that'll
be the first place that you likely hear
about it when the project goes Shea
um there are a couple of things that we
want to get done before going GA content
level resource requests and limits
content level service account
authorization and image management API
and some additional admin tool but once
we get all of those things landed GA
will will follow shortly after that
um the last thing I wanted to make sure
I talk about is that this does not
fundamentally change the user experience
for you as a publisher so just because
we're saying that like now we have the
ability to run content on kubernetes in
a more native office execution Paradigm
does that mean that you as a data
scientist if you're watching today need
to go out and teach yourself a bunch
about what kubernetes is and how to set
it up yourself those are things that you
should rely on your I.T team for and for
you the user experience largely is
unchanged
so if you're used to interacting with
our studio connect this is connect
running on kubernetes if you go to the
documentation page you can scroll down
and you'll see that what we have here
are you used to see your available
versions of our Python and quarto you'll
now see a list of available execution
images and these are the images that
your admin group will make available for
you to use
alongside your connect instance so what
would happen here if I publish just
using my typical normal publishing
pattern either push button or get back
deployment connect will use its version
matching algorithm to select an image on
my behalf so matching the appropriate
version of our python picking one out of
this list if there are several available
and associating that with my piece of
content
if I wanted to Target a specific image
say this image for r344 rather than this
one
I could do that by using an image flag
either in the RS connect deployment uh
function or by specifying it in my
manifest file directly when I go to
write manifest either using the RS
connect
tool inside of our studio with r or the
RS connect python package with python
so really not a whole lot has changed
here you'll see over the next several
months if if you start using office
execution some user interface changes as
we allow more content specific
um features to be specified inside the
UI itself inside the dashboard or um
pre-publish but other than that today
things are largely unchanged and will
grow and add features only iteratively
from here
that's all I had to cover just a quick
quick overview again there's a longer
form version of this talk available on
the conference
website here if you want to see the full
Speed Run installation that's available
too
and that's all I have Sam
thank you Kelly and I'll I'll share the
link to that talk in the chat in just a
second here too I can't hear you ritual
did you meet yourself
foreign
I can hear you
okay and my Kelly maybe your audio is
down
we can hear you we can hear you but
um
I can see some love for uh
what you're showing here I see David
saying interested in talking about this
Kelly can you hear us now
delaying so that before I ask you the
questions I can show them on the screen
um but one of the questions is
can the kubernetes implementation use uh
fairgate or eks
can you see it now Kelly
oh Kelly's figuring out audio settings I
think
all right maybe try turning off
um
your headphones
we can hear you so let me write in the
chat here
let me see I'll see if there are
questions for any of the other talks
that went
went into a slido as well well Kelly's
figuring it out okay
Kelly we heard you perfectly during your
talk so let's see
say something
nope okay you might need to leave us and
come back I'm not sure what happened
there
awesome let me well let's see if anyone
has other questions for either Joe or
James we can um
hop over to those too
let's see
okay James I'm not sure if you can help
with oh you're back you can hear us now
yeah
okay
great no no worries I was gonna start
throwing the questions at James and say
remember when you were in Solutions
engineering you're just gonna take all
of these ones
um awesome so Kelly one of the questions
was is shown on the screen here can the
kubernetes implementation use fairgate
or eks
I don't know about fargate
um but definitely eks yes
eks is what I did the speedrun
installation on
great thank you
um another question over on
YouTube is from deepshat and it is
for shiny publishing when do you
recommend shiny IO versus rstudio
connect is the difference at the
security or off layer primarily
yeah I mean I think that is a question
that is
up to you and your organization like do
you have the resources to run a connect
server yourself this is a self-managed
product so you need to have someone at
the it admin level with Linux
Administration capabilities to run a
server product on the behalf of a data
science team and if you do have that
available connect offers like a lot more
content types A lot more power with
scheduling and a lot more visibility
into like how you're using the product
who is who is accessing your content
items you have a server API that you
control
publishing all the way to like admin
functionality and auditing so you get a
lot more for with connect but shiny apps
IO is amazingly powerful if you don't
have that available to you you still get
some like basic off
um you have to be okay with
um you know like how you're managing
your data if you have data privacy
issues shiny appsio might just be off
the table entirely for you like to start
with but if you don't have those issues
if you don't have an ITT if you have a
smaller use case for a shorter amount of
time shinyapps IO is incredibly powerful
and I recommend it to anybody you get a
couple of apps for free on shinyapps iO
so
it's a great option for undergraduate
graduate students or non-profits you're
just getting started with data products
and data science teams I think it's
amazing
awesome thanks Kelly
I'm gonna jump over to I see James
smiling I didn't know if he was about to
jump in with something too no
I see uh I see a bunch of questions over
on slido as well and one is what is the
recommended architecture to run connect
with kubernetes and I'm really proud of
myself for knowing that that stands for
kubernetes and and why
um connect on a VM and content execution
on kubernetes versus running everything
else or every running everything on
kubernetes
we recommend strongly recommend running
everything in kubernetes including the
connect container image itself so the
pattern that we had originally launched
for workbench where you have workbench
outside of kubernetes and you're
launching sessions into kubernetes that
is that is not holding for connect we've
done the implementation of launcher a
little bit differently for connect and
we prefer if if you use the helm charts
to run the installation process from
start to finish so
that sets up everything inside of
kubernetes for you
um the home charts are amazing and
really easy to use and so if you have
the ability to keep everything inside of
kubernetes strong recommend that you do
that
great thank you
another question over on slido and this
is the first time I've actually seen
pause it in the question is posit
working on a good way for our studio
connect admins to easily add configure
or manage multiple versions such as
multiple python versions R versions
okay
not sure from what angle to answer this
question from do you mean like
what so what is the pain point that
you're hoping we address with multiple
versions of R and python right now we
have the story where you're just
layering in your adding more and more
like versions of R and python I think we
could do a better job of helping you
identify when to remove older versions
of R and python if you feel like that's
necessary to move your content forward
but
there are some server API tools that we
make available you can run reports to
determine like which runtimes are being
used on your server to get a sense for
that to understand like
who has what content how it's being used
whether it's time to pull a version of
our python off the server if that's
important again some to some folks it's
not you'd keep versions of R and python
on their servers for a long time but
um interested in hearing a follow-up
from this person on like
was that what they expected me to say or
did I misinterpret the question entirely
yeah and I know the question was on
slido so it was Anonymous but if you
want to like reply or add anything else
to your question feel free to put that
in there and I can ask it to
and again if you ever want to chat more
with us about it on a call happy to to
help set that up too
um looking over to slido there are a few
other questions
um coming in for Kelly but I also want
to remind everybody that if you have
other follow-up questions for Joe or
James you can put those into the
um chat as well or on slido
if it's not really obvious in your
question to who it's for maybe just put
in their their name as well
but there was a follow-up question Kelly
that was is it possible or feasible to
run workbench entirely on kubernetes
I believe there is and we do have Helm
charts James correct me if I'm wrong for
doing yes that's correct installation
configuration now okay so we are sort of
all all moving in that direction okay
the product's entirely in kubernetes
a uh anonymous question that came in and
I would love to ask this to everybody on
the call too is
um what type of content do you hope
connect will be able to host in the
future
you want us all the answer oh no I meant
like
what we're currently working on
um I meant if people listening in have I
noticed too to share in the chat or in
slido I can make it a question too yeah
I'd absolutely love to hear from the
audience what you'd like to see connect
be able to host in the future I think
what will be focused on in the short
term are
some feature parody work between R and
python you've seen us make a lot of
investments into python space and python
Community to help make python users feel
like we you know we care about them too
we're not just our studio with the r
stuff we want to support python users
also we're really interested in some of
the core functionality that's available
for our users and making that more
accessible to python folks also
so we'll be doing some content work
around that and then Integrations is it
going to be a big Focus for us going
forward and I'll just leave it at that
like
nebulous word
would you like me to throw another hard
question at you here
um
yeah
can anyone please tell me when our
studio will be composite
I can I can share that in the the chat
on their website it says our studio is
becoming positive in October so it is
coming soon but I will share a link
where you can learn more as well
um jumping over to slido and to YouTube
I just want to make sure that I'm not
missing anybody's questions
um so if there's anything I missed feel
free to repost in the YouTube chat or on
LinkedIn so it'll pop up for me but I
think we've covered everything that came
through on slido as well
thank you for answering the poll I see
that 11 people answered the the survey
there
if you didn't and are curious what the
heck I'm talking about here
um on the
the Meetup questions slido we also put a
poll where each of product managers here
Joe James and Kelly put a question to
the audience too
so really appreciate your feedback there
as well
uh let's see I don't see any other
questions coming in but thank you
all so much for
for sharing these updates with us and
sharing what's new and thank you all uh
listening in for all the great questions
as well hope this was helpful I'm
curious to hear your feedback and if
you'd like to see more more of these as
well I really enjoyed it thank you so
much Joe James and Kelly
yes thanks for having us thank you
everyone thanks Rachel
thanks everybody I'm just gonna do one
more plug to say if you are curious in
joining future events you can also use
this short link here we do have meetups
every Tuesday at noon in a data science
hangout every Thursday at noon and love
getting to meet all of you at these
events too so love to see you at Future
ones as well have a great rest of the
day everybody bye